you know for being the first exhibition
game
it's his first three-pointer side step 3
bingo he is 5 for 5 at 4 of them from
downtown trinkets one off that's good in
a foul on Ricky Winslow
Darren unable to finish five seconds to
operate young with a chance to launch
[Music]
deep delete rebound in the game today
1813 prey for three Canon Trey over the
top to Fernando mid floor Trey from the
piston logo yes
Trey Young has 16 in the first period
was resurrected his career at Minnesota
last season Trey deep three from the
wing he's loud here's cam is he putting
on a show very effective with his length
at 611 I guess the hawk Trey
he's got seven Aaron Gordon's had a
relatively quiet night tonight yes you
know and turns it over there Trey got it
off I thought I took bath way through
the fourth quarter
tray all the Hawks did that one tray
recaptures the trouble we're to shoot
three parter for true yo
you are a cheat code the Sixers out with
into this is the first of a back-to-back
for the Hawks will be in Miami tomorrow
night to beat the heat walk Bob Trey
[Applause]
Pembry moves in kicks it out
Alex lamb Trey you called it me 60-56
play the deep three from State Farm
arena
tray pops it up quickly and gets it
they've really extended the defense out
on trade by the Hawks can score here
[Music]
[Applause]
get it going at the other end to Kevin
now it is young with the phrase pray
young is heating up that 80 to 70 for
pray
this key prey with a step back
twenty-eight the nice move very nice
move by Whiteside Trey young there's a
three his first up tonight from distance
just stopping in papa
he is scored Portland's last 10 points
Trey trying to get three of a pack of
dogs for Trey Trey off the screen he's
got 35 Kevin comes off the screen back
to pray long bomb is good
Trey young with his first three-pointer
of the night of the wing in and out
three Morris Trey just outside the logo
strips the cords again for Craig
dependent betray his guard he's hit a
third three a young with a dozen doesn't
really look the part but boy can eat
lunch tray rattles in his fifth
three-pointer former Kansas Jayhawk
41:49 Trey's deep three Potiphar's first
field goal that I Robinson that half
board to get out of his hands he still
was able to get it back 17:55 tray with
the howitzer you knew that one was
coming up with the rebound
63 38 Lakers trade from midcourt
practically just
beside the Laker logo in the league at
doing that another impressive night
LeBron James great quarter for train
38:32 pucks Trey from deep bullseye
Trey yonks trying to get warmed up nice
little sidewalk on the baseline to get
that layup up and in he was an all-star
here in Detroit last year six times in
his career he's gave that honor there's
Trey with a three at Galloway right on
him the best in the league in
three-point percentage years of every
turning the corner out the tray his long
one is gone love to see that first one
go down ray weights at MIT floor now
gets into it with five four from the
logo yes
six-five VanFleet right women Trey will
put up the three trays been up maestro
25 points nine rebounds 9 assists that
jukka's board away from him earlier in
the border and Trey knocks down a huge
three to get in 28 really putting on
some big-time numbers Trey launching
[Applause]
Jabari driving in prey marker ten on the
shot clock tray on the handoff yes
anyone who laden is that here time to
rotate the scene we get that shot
there's Trey young coming off again and
he hits the three if you're not gonna go
on him or blitz out there on him you can
forget it
rebound Atlanta Parker to Trey at the
buzzer
yes sir buddy he nailed that three
marker angles way left alone
no cheat if you cheat on Trey want each
Pacers want all four games against the
Hawks last season for a young going to
work out Brogdon of steps back and heat
drills of three plenty o'clock to work
with supporters chased them all the way
to the way now the step-back three is
good jung-yoon lamb both have ten Trey
things in a long three tray and needed
crossover step back stroll sit Trey
keeps the tricky trouble going step-back
three good again
betrayers Tarvin Vince d'etre public
more at the buzzer good that bucket
counts and it ends up a one-point win
for Indiana Chandler who waited for
Westbrook to get that backdoor play
here's Trey going up swish with contact
from Hardin trade brings it over
Wow Trey he's gonna launch though and he
connects
great brings it ahead there will be a
rematch Wednesday January the 8th and
State Farm arena
about the devil's on that Bruno Fernando
has it
Halle Stein had trade young on him and
had no idea what to do
Marc's looking for that first three it's
Regan young go through his legs nice
move
now kicks it out gets it back tre deep
three good he ends his return to Atlanta
with 23 points
Trey tries a long when it backs it in
freight trains defended by bridges deep
threes
sweat
three young connects he's dancing around
again Zeller
oh nice step back yeah Thank You Trey
young Charlotte Jabari Parker prey in
the launch zone
his first three-pointer of the night and
Miami takes a timeout Frei was sabonis
on him
here's hunter rebound gel tray for three
bottles instead of getting into the shot
clock too quickly
trae young and a tardy switch and Trey
young steps up and drills a three
quarter Anthony Davis and Parker
intercepts you like I said the Lakers a
look careless with the ball there's a
three from Trey young and we are tied at
55 Trey picks up his dribble needs help
gets it back nice step back
[Applause]
three for three he keeps it going shot
Julius Randle hadn't been back in the
game he's been out for a while
tre child's up another three ball tre
stop it pop yes
having at night here at the garden one
2799 one rebound from a double-double
tray drills another three you can't say
is you taught hadn't had any chances
around the back his first up tonight
[Applause]
another middle pick-and-roll with Trent
college this time a three ball by
comment about Jetray young is good three
here can't rate deliver here it is tre
young for three and the Cavalier lead is
down to 821 115 that ends at 10 thing
Atlanta run tre looking for three but
Thompson gets er ballot tray pops it up
and in a three-pointer for tre young
injury to Eric Bledsoe there's no bone
point guard out with a broken leg tray
in and out back in 2016 grass by the
Celtics Fox had a big run early now the
Celtics on a 12o run anything here on
the tray young 3 is for his field goal
three for three and another three for a
young Alex limb
shot clocks wanted down here guys trade
knows it fires up and hits it 17 for
Trey young Pembrey I would like to see
crab take that shot I would too Trey
launching and banking it in conquer the
Cray lon three pulls up time on Boston
congestion on that sideline
Duncan holiday tracking Greg gets the
shot off 10 first corner point for a
young gathers spins on Turner lost it
going up got it back three seconds on
the shot clock phrase three cut
nine-point first quarter for Myles
Turner already 40 points in the first
quarter that is the most that an
opponent has scored
[Applause]
deep three by trade EPS on the gaskets
through the lane bounced to the cutting
peppery picked up through tow out to dre
long bob from that car and again holiday
is in the lane the best shooters out
there in the middle of the floor great
coming down no snap shows up a little
defensive attention tre chips it hits
the three-pointer fourteen first quarter
points on 5 of 7 shooting his second
three tre good prey off the crossover
when your new train was going to take
that shot coming down cramp will shoot
it capela got an arm out there
Allen hustles to get the ball second
chance and praise what is good and with
that the rockets will take a timeout
that's the game plan for the Suns pray
with the deep three sons by a point two
minutes have elapsed
the fourth quarter pray
yes breaks it execution down the stretch
me the keys a long way to go
that's another effective efficient
offensive leads only missed one shot
before the night
Sokol baby that crossover dribble maybe
the fish in the NBA the bully to get to
the lane and he's done the night job at
that Frank lets it go and connects very
difficult three but eight nailed Fitz
needs a little blow right now he seems
to appreciate it but energy comes from
amazing place isn't right now our 42
year old player and the guy who likes to
shoot him from Pareto veggies race
posset tails
[Applause]
three raining another one when the Hawks
beat the Pistons in Detroit opening
night one of the big reasons why is we
limited as trade knocks down his first
of a trade launching how much should
have pulled that out tray lets it go
[Applause]
with the basketball this jock period
three here cop stray my new boots
defended harshly by door throws up a
wild one it hits it but should he get
better the last couple of games but a
cold start here today Trey from deep
[Applause]
Trey launching hitting three where it
was Isaiah Thomas boy here is coming up
tipped pray
beats the Hornet he's done it again
Lachlan Dre dials it's rough deep and 3
ounce okay that's enough of that let me
get some control on his hopin to omit
let me make some things that sense it
the three pray top of the key works on
spit puts up the three
your confidence level goes way up and
that's why coaches always want their
players to play both hands want leads to
the other tray young pretty good
defensive team from Brad Stevens the
head coach of the Hawks a deep three
from Trey and nothing but net my
goodness a 30 footer missed a couple
here and there Collins now to Cray
launching oh he's on it early tonight
fans stay right where you are
averaging just over three points again
three-year career two-time SEC Player of
the Year at Tennessee and praise up to
his old tricks
[Music]
Trey switched out against the 65 mark
3/4 softly the net having that sense of
urgency that helps you know win games
even when it's tough crossover Trey
tray hikers good
Hunter will Bullock and missin rebound
tapped out two columns
good job by David Jones trace first prey
is good pretty well here nine points on
four to five shooting great with a long
bob and hits the three last year in New
Orleans was on with the mixes of
creation 48:46 Trey for three in the
league
yes that's the third three today for
Trey young bins misses trade the middle
they crowd him Trey will just take a
deep great hit
[Applause]
great going out watch burgers got it out
to Teague pack it up fellas
no trades gonna take it who sees it hi
for food now you see them extending the
defense out entree I guess they trying
to do it late he throws up the bomb the
task here Trey drives a deep one whoa
range degree boy Trey from beeps hey
we're all competitors out here then I
think everybody wants to win this game
tonight
first quarters little bit of little bit
of showmanship range forever for Trey
young is that your main man you know you
use it and don't let it don't use it
don't abuse that's right
[Applause]
points of 4 of 6 from the field yes
[Applause]
rebound
[Applause]
but team Yannick says the theta2 brought
of the second quarter 5130 $100,000 goes
to the school matters charity it's a
fast paced game so far - and Miami is
not a deep that flames at a fast pace
tre connects from downtown conscience it
all these guys have no hesitation prey
with the long three ball inside 23:23
another bomb
and another three-pointer Trey waits for
the screen gets the contact nine three
from Miami
Trey puts up the rainbow it hits it
against Iguodala to bio and Butler Trey
tie game and my MA takes a timeout and
they continue let and now they starting
to switch the lead you got plenty
o'clock
is deficit to one
[Applause]
but that just gave 5 Alito now
Tradeworks the deep three and hits it
[Applause]
they're trying to keep it under trays
hands they cannot he gets the three away
that's it with 0.5 tray young folks
Atlanta ahead 92 291 hurt her tray
grates it got a great look 50 45 will
think a roll layup is what worship
referencing 50 45 magic tray for three
yes duck longs baseline Graham gets rid
of it here's tray
24 portray young Trey with the bomb got
it
[Music]
Trey young surveys steps back deep three
got he was backpedaling when he let it
go Lamar he had a feeling friend
steps back on gorget Jack and drill is
it with three seconds to go in the
period Hornets have played well
defensively of late they're coming off a
big win over Houston Trey will launch
the log one and hit it to start his
night on 50% shooting Hawks lead by
three on 73% shooting a trade with
another from the wing
Pike scores on the board in this first
half
three fries for Trey young and logo man
makes his return Atlanta's first play of
the third quarter Trey pizza
now the switch Trey gets rid of it
Kevin drives it back to Trey for the
bomb god box go up by one well we're
talking about the Knicks offense and
they've done an excellent job their
defense is what's been so good as Trey
young Peyton took his eyes off him gave
him time to set heartless who finished
hard at the rim Trey
[Applause]
back heel may have been on the logo
today if the door is opening for the
Hawks here tray for up deep yes Knicks
Kevin try to get it back to Trey he'll
watch from the longer a young guns it
again and this is a two-point ballgame
for Hart place who finished hard at the
rim Trey
[Applause]
back heel may had been on the logo today
if the door is opening for the Hawks
here tray for up deep Knicks 996 leap
for New York Trey young from three and
he puts it down 14 to shoot
Kevin gets it in Trey from the corner
three good Trey connects he's got 34
Kevin trying to get it back to Trey
he'll watch from the locker
Trey young guns it again and this is a
two-point ballgame